[Music]
just a few weeks ago on September 22nd a
group of Egyptians raised the rainbow
flag at amateur Leila concert this led
to the widest crackdown and arrests of
LGBT individuals in Egypt regarding
human rights violations the victims have
been dealing with physical abuse
beatings groping cursing they've also
had limitations put on their family and
legal visitations they've also had anal
examinations this treatment is
tantamount to torture now according to
the UN any arrests based on gender
identity or sexual orientation are by
definition arbitrary and therefore
violate international law the Egyptian
media has an immediate response after
every crackdown by making the queer
identity synonymous with terrorism
debauchery and prostitution Jima is okay
Thomas Mattson horrific lock figure I
need men hot rod to actually walk fools
people have been using scare tactics and
propaganda since the beginning of time
it's our responsibility to look past
these scare tactics and see humanity
instead on a bright note eyes are on
Egypt right now showing solidarity and
support protests are occurring all over
the world
you have queer people queer Egyptians
who may have located two other countries
outside of their own and they're getting
attention and they're getting support
and love and solidarity and they may
have been existing this entire time with
that same fear instilled in them there
are queer Egyptians around the world
right now
looking over and feeling visible and
feeling seen and heard and love to my
siblings suffering in prison you're not
alone to my career family around the
globe
your suffering is not going to go
unheard
we are working really hard to make sure
that these human rights violations don't
occur again and to those already in
prison for this we're working hard to
get you out look for links below to show
support and solidarity there are so many
organizations and initiatives beginning
and springing up and if you want to
start your own that would be amazing to
be honest I spent I eat soon bring hope
back to bring back to bring love back to
Egypt I'm a naval veteran and I stand
with my aging I'm with clear Egypt I
love you guys I stand with you guys
we're here we're thinking of you and we
love you
[Music]
[Music]